Vivek Bald: Will Freudenheim.
And the title of Will's thesis
is The Network and the
Classroom: A History of
Hypermedia Learning
Environments. And I'm going to
hand it over to Eric to
introduce.
Eric Klopfer: Thanks, Vivek,
before before I introduce Will,
I just wanted to say how
excellent all the work has been,
but also to note how diverse
it's been. And yet, the whole
student community has been
clearly supportive of each
other. And I just want us to
give a call out to the whole
student community for their work
through through challenging
times here. So thank you to all
of you for that. And so now,
I'll introduce well, and so I
first met Will, a couple of
years ago at PAX East. He had
applied to the program, I think
he had gotten into the program
and I met him at PAX East to see
some of his work that he was
working on in games, and was
thrilled that when he was
announced he was coming to the
program. Because he had done
such great work there. I came
here started working on I'm
actually I'm wearing a playful
dream lab official garment here,
where he's been working at MIT,
and start doing work on games
and continued to work on some of
the work on games and assessment
there but found his thesis
passionate interest around
hypermedia and, and I've been
I've learned a lot through his
journey through hypermedia and
looking at its relationship to
education and learning. And
noted that he takes I don't want
to give too much away, but he's
give sort of a historical
perspective on hypermedia and
that history sort of coincides
with my lifetime. So I've kind
of lived along a lot of the
thesis work that we'll be
talking about today. So with
that, I will let will take it
away.
Will Freudenheim: Thank you so
much, Eric. Let me just share my
screen here. Okay, you may be
blessed today a little bit with
some new york city traffic
noises throughout my
presentation. Okay, so I'm going
to begin Can everybody see this?
This visible? Okay, great. So
I'm going to begin with some of
the personal kind of origins of
this topic for me. I was one of
those students growing up, who
immediately upon graduating high
school felt like I had kind of
already forgotten a significant
portion of what I have learned
throughout my years of
education. And as I began
college, for the first time, I
had the opportunity to choose
classes not only that I was
excited about, but that
overlapped with each other in
different ways that felt
meaningful to try to document
build upon and return to.
Throughout this time, I thought
that kind of like lingering
anxiety that I would come away
from these years of school
feeling like I had when I
finished high school that I'd
had all these deeply meaningful
discussions and lectures and
readings, which would soon kind
of drift out of memory. So what
I realized I was looking for was
a system for organizing my own
knowledge that could act like a
thinking partner, not just an
ever growing pile of notebooks
and readings, but a system for
organizing ideas that could let
thoughts intermingle, that could
accompany my learning, and that
would be valuable and generative
to return to and explore, and
ideally a tool that I could use
in collaboration with others to
share ideas as we learned. So in
the past five years, there have
been actually an explosion in
popularity of these types of
tools for creating network
systems for organizing and
sharing knowledge. And while
this type of tool isn't always
described using one single term,
I refer to this genre of tool as
hypermedia knowledge
organization tools, and I'll
take a moment to kind of break
that down. So at its most
simple, hypermedia, the term
hypermedia comes from hypertext,
which refers to text which is
not constrained to be linear and
where the text itself contains
linkages to other text or other
documents which a user can kind
of follow based on their own
interest. And then from there
comes hypermedia more broadly,
which refers to systems where
other media forms like images
and video can be connected in
similar ways. The most obvious
example of hypertext and
hypermedia is the internet
itself, where you follow
hyperlinks to navigate networks
of pages and content. And then
when I say knowledge
organization tools, I'm
referring quite broadly to tools
and practices which helped
arrange and document ideas and
concepts. So taken together
hypermedia knowledge
organization tools refers to
tools which allow users to
document organize and develop
ideas which employ these
practices of linking and network
forming to to form these like
networks of interconnected
thoughts. So Many of these
recent tools promised to
positively affect how people
think, learn and generate ideas.
These new tools make claims for
helping people create a second
brain in this example here, by
creating and following
connections between notes and
ideas. they emphasize nonlinear
note taking and knowledge
organizing, and typically employ
imagery as well as user
interfaces that incorporate
these interconnected nodes of
ideas. which you can see here.
This is a tool called Rome
research. Furthermore, they
emphasize collaboration and
connection making across
contexts is another tool called
arena where you can locate
single ideas in multiple folders
at once. And then finally, many
of these tools propose that
thinking and learning happen in
these shared organizing spaces.
So while these recent tools make
pretty lofty claims about their
new features to help create
context for improved thinking
and learning, they build upon
both technology and pedagogy
that has been developing since
the early days of personal
computers. Despite this history,
and its links to these tools,
and enter learning itself, we
see little transformation of the
classroom as connected to these
types of tools today. Why is
this and can or should we seek
to change that? So in this in
this thesis, I asked, How can
classrooms use emerging systems
for collaboratively sharing and
organizing knowledge in order to
benefit learners? And how can we
learn from the past in order to
better shape the future of this
work? I argue that examining the
history of hypermedia oriented
learning tools by looking at
both successful and failed
experiments and bring them to
classrooms, one can more deeply
understand both the conceptual
origins of these recent
networked knowledge tools, and
consider where they might be
able to fit into today's
classrooms, as well as how to
avoid challenges that have
plagued them in the past.
So indeed, there's a whole
lineage of these types of
interactive and collaborative
tools for organizing knowledge
as networks that have been
experimented with in classrooms.
Since the 1980s. In this thesis,
I look at two previous moments
of intense development in this
space, one in the mid 1980s, and
another in the mid 2000s. Before
then turning to examine these
tools in the present moment. At
each of these points, I look at
technological shifts, as well as
trends in the learning sciences,
which together inform both the
design and application of these
tools. In doing so, I examine
and draw lessons from the
frictions involved in using
these tools in educational
contexts, in order to consider
and propose ways in which these
new tools might be able to be
used to support learning in
classrooms today. As I do so, I
look at emulations and technical
documentation, older software, I
look at advertisements,
promotional material and video
content of people using these
tools. Then Then I serve a
pretty wide variety of research
studies describing the
application of hypermedia
learning tools and learning
contexts from each of these
points. So in this presentation,
today, I'm going to do kind of
two things. First is give sort
of a quick historical overview
of the development of these
tools and the connections
between hypermedia and learning
as they've developed and discuss
some of the frictions between
educational media hypermedia and
classrooms along the way. And
then I'll shift gears and
describe the current generation
of these tools and point to
three approaches. But these
types of tools could be used in
classrooms, one of which I
implemented in a middle school
classroom context in the fall.
But before getting there, I want
to touch on why why this area is
important. Firstly, building new
capacities to document organize
and structure knowledge is a
crucial 21st century skill, and
one that becomes ever more
relevant when encountering
increasing information,
information saturation that we
all deal with today. However,
making changes to education
broadly, is an incredibly
challenging task. And
particularly in the context of
educational technology, new
tools, with great promise come
in and out of popularity quite
regularly, and very rarely make
any significant changes in
popular educational discourse.
In his book, failure to disrupt
why technology alone can't
transform education, Justin
Reich talks in depth about why
so many of the technologies
which have been promised will
radically transform educational
practices have failed. He sets
forth the juxtaposition between
two stances, the charismatic
stance and the tinkering stance.
The charismatic stance typically
accompanies technological
innovation, the notion that
technology itself inherently
will offer wholesale
transformation of existing
systems, and it's this stance
that often fails. In comparison,
the tinkering stance, he says,
sees schools and universities as
complex systems which can be
improved, but they believe that
major improvement is the product
of many years of incremental
changes to existing institutions
rather than the result of one
stroke of wholesale renewal. So
with this thesis, I hope to take
a tinkerer stance on considering
the possible value of these
types of tools. I see this and
trying to pull lessons from the
Earlier errors of hypermedia
learning that I examine and
consider how these how these
tools might be able to offer
some incremental changes to
classrooms. So first I'm going
to talk a little bit about some
of the origins of the connection
between hypermedia and, and
learning. So any account of the
history of hypertext and
hypermedia tends to begin with
Vannevar Bush. He was an
American engineer and inventor,
and led the US Office of
Scientific research and
development throughout World War
Two. Following the war, Bush
sought to imagine schools as
sorry, imagine tools, which
might be able to enable the
human mind to more readily think
and learn across disciplines. In
part this stemmed from a fear
that the increasing hyper
specialization which he saw
amongst his research
organizations would lead to a
mountain of inaccessible
knowledge. It is 1945 piece in
The Atlantic titled as we may
think, Bush proposed a device
called the memex. To deal with
this challenge. The memex was a
device which would hold
microfilm copies of a user's
personal library, and allow them
to make automatic connections
between text such that they
could create chains of
intertextual Association. Users
of the memex device would save
and share these paths of ideas
between texts as well as their
notes about them. As is apparent
in the title of this piece, Bush
wanting to develop a device that
he operates as he believed, we
may think.
This notion that the mind
naturally operates by
association carries throughout
this entire text. As he says,
with one item in its grasp, the
brain instantly snaps to the
next that is suggested by the
Association of thoughts in
accordance with some intricate
web of trails carried by the
cells of the brain. So embedded
in his writing are few notions
about learning that carry across
many of the hypermedia tools for
organizing knowledge that
developed in the following
years. First is the idea that
the mind naturally thinks and
learns by making these
associations. The second is that
associations between ideas can
link together from one to the
next to form trails of
connection as Bush describes,
developing tools by which one
can create and save these trails
will allow for deeper learning.
And then third is that these
trails are meaningful chunks of
knowledge which can be built
collaboratively, where sharing
and co creating networks of
association between ideas will
inherently lead to deeper
learning. And then, in the 20.
In the 20 years that followed,
the terms hypertext and
hypermedia themselves were later
coined by Ted Nelson in the
1960s, who imagined digital
systems which would use these
models. He created diagrams to
illustrate the idea of hypertext
and hypermedia, one of which you
can see here and this this
imagery is often repeated
throughout the types of tools
that we look at today. So
Unknown: okay, yes.
Will Freudenheim: Though this
optimism in the power of
hypermedia to accelerate
learning remained semi dormant
for a few decades in terms of
tools that were actually
developed. By the mid 1980s.
Multiple hypermedia platforms
simultaneously sprung forth that
were specifically designed for
the educational context.
Researchers from across
educational and commercial
institutions promised that
hypermedia oriented learning
tools would offer learners newer
and faster ways of accessing
knowledge, new modes of
collaboration, and new types of
interaction to enable learners
to forge connections between
ideas. By the mid 20th century,
new theories of knowledge
acquisition began to describe
learning and thinking as
processes using computational
and diagrammatic metaphors,
which sounded much like Ted
Nelson and Vannevar Bush's early
descriptions of hypertext
systems. These perspectives on
learning were foundational in
bridging the language of
hypertext to the language of
learning, which deeply informed
the educational hypermedia tools
to come. So I'm going to talk
about two of them briefly. One
model of learning that stands
out for its overlap with
hypertext vocabulary is the
model of schemas, a concept from
psychology and cognitive science
which describes patterns of
thought or behavior which
organize information and the
relationships between them. The
model of schema, considers
mental constructs as individual
nodes which together form
networks of ideas through
associative structures, which
consist of attributes and
relationships between them.
schemas, focus attention on the
role that old knowledge plays an
inquiry in acquiring new
knowledge in the sense that new
knowledge is filtered and
interpreted through these webs
of pre existing associations.
Another important model to
understand learning that was
growing in popularity at this
time was the idea of social
constructivism. In the
educational context, social
constructivism emphasizes the
deeply collaborative nature of
learning, suggesting that
knowledge develops through how
people interact with each other,
their culture and society at
large. classroom learning,
students rely on others to help
create their own building blocks
with which they incorporate new
ideas and interpret their
existing assumptions about
reality. So thinking about the
computer as an educational tool
in the context of schemas and
social constructivism, it became
clear that computers could be
used as tools to think with
hypertext based tools could
readily act as a digital
environment through which
learners could model and extend
the social construction of
knowledge. By creating open and
unstructured databases that
allow for collaboration,
learners can add and connect
ideas and support and challenge
each other's perspectives. So at
the same time as all this was
happening, new developments in
computing were simultaneously
essential in creating the
conditions for these these new
educational hypertext
experiences to develop. So, just
to give a kind of overview of
the like early 80s moment, in
1981, IBM was releasing its
first personal computer, which
was the first again bats of
industry adoption, or France
Telecom offered the mentelle
terminals, which became the
largest online service before
the World Wide Web. In 82, LAN
operating systems emerged, which
allowed network links between
computers and offices. In 83,
Microsoft introduced for 84, the
CD ROM exploded in popularity.
So 1985 potentially computers,
commercial computers become
powerful enough to store and
manipulate multi just as
networking practices were
becoming increasingly possible
the business sector, both of
which are crucial in developing
the types of interactive
platforms that come. So I'm
going to talk about one of the
hypermedia knowledge
organization tools that was
developed during this time
called intermediate. So
intermediate was a hypermedia
tool developed at Brown
University, but 1985 and 1991.
The tool the project was
accompanied by by a team of both
computer scientists and
ethnography, who produced
research papers about how it was
received, as well as selected
documentary footage. At the
outset of this project, the team
describes intermediate as a
vision to create a vast
multimedia information
environment where no piece of
information is ever isolated,
and where every word picture and
idea can be linked to any other
intermediate was not so much one
tool as it was a suite of
applications, which explains its
kind of plural name. You can get
a sense of this from the
screenshot here, where you can
see on the left a web that was
created, which links out to
multiple documents on 19th
century health records, and each
of the documents themselves
linked to each other. And then
over on the right, you can see a
kind of like history of all the
different kinds of edits and
linkages that people were
creating and building. So in the
ethnographic report, students
referred to working with
intermediate as going to
intermediate because all the
intermediate terminals were
housed in one room. So to them
this experience of intermediate
was not as much the software as
it was the content held in the
software as it was the physical
space that house it was this
kind of total experience.
The first intermediate pilot
with two was with two classes at
Brown, an English survey course
and a biology course, the two
courses were selected as a proof
of concept of the flexibility of
the system. If the same tool can
be used to enhance learning in
the distinct cultures of the
sciences and the humanities,
then surely it would be useful
to a broader selection of
courses. The professors for the
each course and the research
team together built an entire
corpus of reference materials
for the work before the before
the courses began. In putting in
linking hundreds of documents
together, students could
contribute their own content to
their to the intermediate
environment by adding their own
writing by linking elements from
their own or others work
together. We're inputting other
resource materials, while
students and educators often
have a range of experiences
using intermedia over the course
of the entire semester. The
learning outcomes of engaging
with this tool were considered
largely quite successful, both
in terms of student's
performance on exams for the
biology course, as well as the
kind of depth of connection
making and discussion for the
students in the English course.
So this is one example of the
types of experiments that was
occurring during this time. In
the thesis, I talked about two
other significant hypermedia
knowledge organization tools
from this era. One is called
Cecil, which later turned into a
tool called Knowledge Forum, and
another called hypercard, which
was not explicitly educational,
but was used quite a bit in
educational contexts. However,
looking across the research
studies from from throughout
these three tools, and about the
various ways that they were used
in classrooms, at this time, a
few kind of patterns of
frictions become clear. So many
of these early experiments
required so much pre setup like
intermediate where professors
and a team of workers entered a
huge amount of material before
the course began. While some of
these early experiments were
themselves successful, and
learners had positive
experiences, they were typically
quite unrealistic to imagine
setting up at any larger scale.
Furthermore, there was quite a
significant number of technical
challenges with using these
tools as well. So operating
networks, computer labs at that
point was expensive and not what
not yet a norm. Loading and
interacting with network systems
could at times be incredibly
slow and cumbersome. And this
was particularly a big problem
for intermedia. And then for
many just becoming familiar with
interacting with the computer
was was a new experience and
required a significant
onboarding time. So that's like
a little picture of this mid
1980s moment. Shifting forward
now, I'll describe kind of a
moment, a bit of the time in
between them, we'll jump to the
2000s. So despite the the
failure of the tools from the
1980s and early 90s, to gain
widespread traction in
classrooms, By the mid 1990s, it
was becoming increasingly clear
that the world was rapidly
changing alongside developments
and mass popularization of
computers and the early
internet. In popular educational
discourse, there were a
plurality of descriptions of
what this future computer
enabled world would look like
and notions of how to adapt
educational practices in order
to better prepare learners for
this new landscape. By 2005, the
broad shifts toward a more
highly interactive internet only
further fueled excitement about
participatory web based learning
tools. This broad shift in how
websites were designed, was
described as web 2.0, a term
used for new websites that were
structured to enable user
generated and participatory
content and interactions with
things like the growth of social
media, blogs and video sharing
sites. At the same time, abroad,
an interdisciplinary pedagogical
approach called computer
supported collaborative
learning, or cscl, was beginning
to gain significantly more
traction in cscl approaches
which build upon a combination
of educational psychology,
instructional technology and
social psychology. learning
occurs through social
interactions using shared
digital spaces where learners
collaboratively construct
knowledge using technology as
their primary means of
communication or as a shared
resource. Though the CSGO
community had existed for a few
decades, the availability of
more collaborative platforms on
the internet led to a
significant expansion in the
CSGO community and its research.
Many educational researchers
across CL and other disciplines
took this collaborative
potential and growing popularity
of the internet and imagine how
these tools could be used in
concert with a broadly
constructivist learning
strategies to enable learners to
more effectively participate in
a networked society. So of these
new web 2.0 platforms that were
rapidly growing in popularity,
the wiki became a format onto
which researchers began to
imagine new possibilities for
developing collaborative
learning experiences in the
classroom.
Unknown: So while everyone is
likely familiar with Wikipedia,
which is the most widely known
wiki, wiki is generally wikis
more broadly are a kind of
general form of hypertext
publication that is
collaboratively edited and
managed directly inside of the
web browser. Wikis themselves
run wiki engines, many of which
are freely open source and could
be readily tinkered with by
researchers and educators. So
while in the kind of first
section of my thesis, I looked
at kind of a spread of different
tools and how they were used in
classrooms. In this chapter I
typically I focus on wikis as a
kind of general model, which
were and continue to be used in
a wide variety of different
learning contexts. So there are
a few. There are a number of
aspects of how wikis are
designed that are particularly
appeal to this kind of
constructivist approach. Like
earlier hypermedia models, wikis
allow users to organize and
present content in a way that
does not prescribe a set
organizational form at the
outset, and can allow for kind
of organic growth. Wikis use
pages as nodes which can refer
to each other to form a network
which does not need to be pre
determined. This offers the
potential for students to build
out wikis as they follow self
directed learning, adding or
linking new pages as they
potentially follow their own
interests. So beginning around
2005, educators and researchers
proposed and developed a wide
variety of learning experiences
which brought with these into
the classrooms across a variety
of different maturities of
learners across different
subject areas and across
contexts. So I'll talk about a
few sort of like general models
of wikis that were used in
education. The first is a
resource wiki. So resource wikis
are collaborative knowledge
bases where learners contribute
to their contribute their
knowledge to an expanding
encyclopedic resource. Resource
wikis are typically more outward
facing, meaning that they're
less intended to contain in
progress documentation of
learning processes, and instead
are able to function as a
knowledge base that could be
legible and potentially useful
to external readers beyond the
class itself. students might be
assigned to creating specific
article style entries,
integrating text and images and
attribution to cited articles.
These types of wikis are
intended to perform like
Wikipedia as a resource
containing reliably sourced
information. One one related
genre of wiki usage involves
presentation with use, which are
a way of using wikis to create a
document in progress learning
And knowledge in a format that
is less concerned with being
presentable to an outsider, and
more focused on being useful for
learners. Presentation Wikis
have more room for individuals
to use their own writing styles
and tones. And while while
learners using presentation
wikis will link their pages and
ideas to get there, it's more
likely to be intentionally
parent who developed each page
on the wiki in order to assess
the contributors as well.
Presentation Wikis are more
likely to have segmented areas
where contributors are working
individually or collaboratively
in private spaces, where more
finished work will kind of be
added to the publicly accessible
zone on completion. And then,
one third example of using wikis
that I mentioned just briefly is
using them for co writing as an
opportunity to bring students
away from the kind of
traditional solitary mode of
written work and toward
collective writing processes
which offer not only
opportunities for to practice
reading and writing but involves
critical thinking, reflection
and like regular interaction. So
reflecting on the years of
research using wikis and
classrooms, there are a number
of different kinds of challenges
in using them that stand out
from from the challenges that
the tools in the mid 80s dealt
with. One significant One was
that evaluating both performance
and individuals contributions in
this context is very difficult
for shared and collaborative
spaces. These evaluations became
increasingly crucial during the
2005 forward era of heightened
standardized testing and No
Child Left Behind. Secondly,
more meta research from 2009.
And so onward, indicated that in
many cases, learners didn't
actually display deeply
collaborative behaviors using
them. So this was often the case
where when students like
procrastinate, they vastly
reduced the possibility for
collaboration. Like when working
against a time crunch, students
are like less likely to take the
time to reflect on each other's
work, or thoughtfully cross
reference between Wiki pages and
are much more likely to focus on
just finishing their own
content. Furthermore, working
with limited time, learners
don't typically can typically
give in progress feedback to
their peers.
Will Freudenheim: Furthermore,
wikis themselves, typically, by
default, are much more stripped
down than than some of the
earlier tools, even the ones
described in the 80s in the
sense that they don't have built
in modes of visualizing networks
of ideas, and and where content
or individual nodes can only
live in one place rather than a
plurality of them at once. And
then one final one final
friction in classrooms was that
discussion areas on Wikis are
typically separated out from the
content areas. And so having
deeper discussions was
challenging to point to
specific, specific notes in the
wiki. Alright, so now I'm going
to shift gears a little bit and
talk about some of the
contemporary hypermedia tools
for knowledge organization, some
of the features of them and then
describe kind of three
applications that I see them
being used in today's
classrooms. So as I mentioned,
at the at the opening of this
presentation, there have been a
variety of new types of tools
which draw upon this nonlinear
network oriented model of
documenting and organizing
knowledge. The design of this
recent generation of tools
combines many of the important
design aspects from each of the
previous points that I examined
earlier. So like the mid 2000s,
kind of wiki moment, these
recent hypermedia knowledge
organization tools are, are
accessible and primarily browser
based. They are synchronously
editable, meaning that users can
actually see each other's
changes in real time. But these
tools also borrow a lot of the
design decisions from the 80s as
well, many of which emphasize
the importance of multi
contextuality, where one idea
can simultaneously link out to
multiple places at once rather
than kind of one directional
link. They prioritize creating
and connecting smaller nodes of
information. So while with the
wiki where the page was kind of
the individual node that could
connect to other pages, many of
these contemporary tools
prioritize creating and
connecting smaller chunks of
information together like
individual bullet points, or
individual images. And then
finally, many of these emerging
platforms offer multiple ways of
creating and viewing the
connections between information
and their relationships as well,
so often employing graph views
to kind of visualize nodes of
interconnection. So the final
section of my thesis then asks,
Where might these ideas and
platforms fit into classrooms
today? And how can we learn from
some of these frictions of
previous tools? So I identify
three possible ways that I see
these contemporary tools being
used. that avoids some of the
information frictions. And each
of these models are just
inspired by practices that I've
seen people using online. The
first is the concept of creating
a digital garden. So digital
gardens are online spaces that
looks something like a
combination of a notebook and a
blog. Digital gardeners write
essays or short form pieces and
use backlinks at the end of each
page to point to other pieces
inside their garden to connect
to the piece that the reader is
currently reading to others,
it's like a kind of personal
website or a blog with the added
notion that the written pieces
are intentionally interlinked
together. And in addition, this
kind of garden metaphor implies
that the connections on each
page as well as the content
itself, will be tended to, and
that the posts themselves aren't
meant to be final but can grow
later on. Digital gardens are a
model that could be useful in a
variety of contexts. But for an
example, a middle school age
learner and an English class
could use a digital garden to
write not only their homework,
assignments, essays and creative
work in one shared space, and
could be encouraged to
explicitly make connections
between these different forms.
This model is developed by an
individual rather than a group,
and is more focused on
organizing and sharing work that
a learner has themselves created
rather than inputting knowledge
created by others. So this has
the benefit of giving teachers a
space with which to evaluate the
student's work as they use the
tool. A second approach is using
these shared knowledge
organization tools for creating
collaborative research
repositories. So using these
tools, learners that are part of
a class or group of classes can
collectively gather, organize
and annotate external materials
that will be useful for research
and writing that will be
developed separately. This is a
type of practice that I've seen
on one of the tools called arena
that I examined previously. This
type of model will allow
students to help each other
gather materials that will be
useful for their own individual
work, and in doing so builds a
shared system that is
potentially useful to the entire
class as a whole. And while this
model is inherently
collaborative, it's in a kind of
prewriting context that avoids
the challenges of needing to
figure out how to grade
individual students on their
contributions.
And then the third model that I
talked about, which is what I
explore in a little bit more
depth in a case study is using
network tools to support social
emotional learning in
classrooms. This model is
inspired by a project that I
worked on with the playful
journey lab at MIT. In
collaboration with a seventh
grade, Massachusetts area public
middle school classroom in the
fall, we used a tool called
brown research, which is one of
the contemporary tools that I
like over in the thesis to host
an activity series format that
focused on collaborative
reflection, in order to support
students and teachers to
acknowledge a kind of wide
variety of experiences and types
of learning that that happened
throughout the pandemic. The
types of prompts that we
designed, involved virtual
making and collaborative
writing, that that is also
incorporated like drawing simple
video making and taking
pictures. The intention was that
students would come away from
this activity series with this
co created collection of shared
artifacts that captured this
moment in their lives. That led
to like deeper discussion. And
that helped expand their ideas
of what learning is. And in
doing so, they worked in this
kind of shared knowledge
environment over the course of a
semester. Using using the to
these tools in this context is,
again, kind of outside of a
context that requires grading,
and also further further
encourages collaboration and
connection forming. And then
also, using using these tools
for a shared social emotional
space, could be a way to help
learners in distance learning
environments as well. Also also
developing an activity series in
this using this format, is a way
of avoiding some of the
procrastination problems that
Wikipedia or the sorry that
Wikis often dealt with. I could
talk a lot more about this
specific project. But I'm going
to kind of start to start to
wrap up. So looking at both the
history and present moment of
network tools in the context of
learning. My hope today is to
kind of leave you with a gentle
optimism about their potential.
Well, I don't see these tools on
their own as radically are
fundamentally transforming
educational practices, I see
that there clearly is a design
space that can be continued to
be explored using these types of
tools to support learners in a
variety of different contexts.
So I think that taking a
tinkerers approach to looking at
the past configurations of the
genre of tool and carefully
examining the contexts within
which they can be employed is
essential to using them to
create change. And then
ultimately, what what is more
important, most important is
less the tools themselves but
careful consideration of how
they fit into the environments
in which we use them. So thank
you all so much. Thank you to
Eric and Justin for for all of
your help, as well as everybody
here.
Take a sip of water.
Vivek Bald: All right. We're
open for questions. Eric.
Unknown: Thanks, Will. I enjoyed
hearing your presentation there.
And, of course, going through
this, this journey with you. And
my question, this is a little
bit of a little bit of a
hypothetical situation. But I
also asked in the context of
this for the tinkerer and the
charismatic. And so you should
have documented this case of, of
tinkering over decades in this
in this space of hypermedia with
respect to schools. So imagine,
imagine you can take one of the
tools use for mentioned on the
last slide there, perhaps the
one they used in the school's
Rome and and bring it back to a
1980s classroom? So here you
are, you're the charismatic, who
can bring this this technology
of the future to the classroom?
And will it be more effective
than the things that they were
using at the time? And that the
context of my question is like,
is it? Is it the process of
tinkering that's important? Or
is it the product of tinkering
that's important that we get to
that place through this for
these years of tinkering?
Will Freudenheim: Yeah, I think
I think it has to be a
combination, in the sense that I
think just even even dropping
one of these contemporary tools,
even if you will, also brought
with it like the, you know, the
computers to it, to that point,
would still I think there would
still be a lot of the same kinds
of frictions encountered, I
think that like, it's this
process of tinkering over the
course of many years that
develops a kind of like language
around how to how to bring them
into classrooms. And like
pedagogical approaches that that
like are carefully considered
over over the course of years,
that that find their fit at a
certain point. And so I think
that, while while some of the
tools at that point were
themselves quite effective. I
think that it's it's the kind of
process of tinkering, but it's
important. Yeah. Thanks,
William.
William Uricchio: Well, thanks.
That was that was terrific,
brilliant history. And what I
want to learn a lot more about
can't wait to read it. Just to
pick up on Eric's question. And
the very last point you made
where you said, it's more about
the fit, it's less about the
tools, and it's more about the
fit in the context. It strikes
me as just another way to read
like, the, the information
you've amassed is as a, a moment
in his eyes the moment in in the
kind of technological remapping
of how consciousness works on
how learning works. If you were
to jump back, a century and a
half, you know, when photography
was the hot medium, there's a
lot of emphasis being put on
like, Well, can we learn with
slides? Can we learn with image?
How does the mind work? There's
this kind of pod to do between
the representation systems that
are being used in the classroom,
and the model of how mental
processes work, like, well, we
hold images, or it's a blank
slate, or it's a photographic
memory. That's a discourse
that's really big in the in the,
in the mid 19th century. So what
strikes me is just the kind of
the, this goes to Eric's point
in the question, I guess, like
there is a kind of Zeitgeist, a
paradigm, a notion of how
consciousness works that we that
we technologically emulate. And
it's not whether the tool is
good or bad. It's whether that
fit, it's strikes me You're so
apt to last thing you said it's
less the tools, and more the fit
in the context. I'm using
context in a different way than
you used it. But I think it's
still it's still kind of works
well to know if you have any
reactions to that, or whatever.
But it just strikes me as a
brilliant meditation on our
thinking about the learning
process and our thinking about
the functioning of consciousness
through technology as the lens.
Yeah,
Unknown: it's a really
interesting point. I think that
I mean, I was quite struck by
the fact that like this, this
like, associative metaphor, and
this like image of these, like
interconnected documents is like
persisted now for I mean, Nelson
kind of was developing that that
model in the 60s and like,
we're, like, you see these brand
new tools that are claimed that
like, pretend to be entirely a
historical, that are like
referencing this exact same
diagram. So and I and I'm, it's
something that I wonder like,
if, if perhaps it's like,
through, you know, now, however
many years of in good deep
engagement with the internet
that like maybe that this model
is more ready to be used than it
had been previously that like,
the types
Maybe we're starting to see cra
ks in the system, and that yo
gave them three examples that
ou're focusing on and one w
s the garden. And I'm wonder
ng if like there's not an ecol
gical model that's start
ng to displace this technol
gical computational model. Li
e you say another way devil's ad
ocate now is to say it's appeal
ng to a new metaphor. And it'
more organic, more organi
Will Freudenheim: That's really
interesting. Yeah, I mean, I've
seen it. That's something that I
know a little bit at the end of
the thesis is that I see this
kind of gardening metaphor
actually used quite a bit more
in relation to these tools that
might even perhaps, like kind of
overtake the sort of network
metaphor down the road. And
that's something Yeah, that's
something I would love to see
happen.
Vivek Bald: Justin.
Justin Reich: thanks. Well, this
has been really terrific. Can
everybody hear me okay? Yep,
bad, bad connections in Vermont.
I wanted to, you know, a
terrific history, lots of great
connections, and Eric and
William questions, but not quite
a bit. One challenge I wanted to
offer is that it sounded like in
your final piece, you were
saying something along the lines
of if we could get teachers to
choose the right kind of
projects to do with Rome
research, then that would
alleviate some of the problems
with previous generations, which
is makes me think that that's an
argument that it was the
projects in previous generations
that were wrong. I wonder if you
could talk about what's actually
having an alternative view that
it's not that the projects were
wrong, nor is that the case that
you could take the perfect room
projects and have them fit. It's
that there's a series of values
in schools that are orthogonal
to the values of learning and
participating with these tools.
Will Freudenheim: Right. I think
that Yeah, that's a great point.
So yeah, I
think that the that it is true
that often the values of schools
absolutely are orthogonal to
effectively using these types of
tools. I guess what I'm trying
to propose is that there are
still ways of using them in
inside of the existing kind of
structures of schools that can
still be effective. I don't know
if that completely answers your
question.
Unknown: But, yeah, I think I
think you just use it as well,
just something like, Oh, I can't
change schools. So but there's
probably like little niches
where were sufficiently devoted
people will make this work. So
here's some great ways of doing
that. And I think that's good,
too. Although, although I think
that, you know, they're there,
they're, you know, that which is
a, which is a great way of
continuing to develop really
interesting pedagogy for the
coalition of the willing. And
I'm interested in whether Rome
or whatever, you know, garden
metaphors are, what other kinds
of things might expand that
coalition of the willing in
interesting ways?
Yeah, I mean, I think that I
think that expanding the
coalition of the willing is, I
guess, kind of where, where I'm
sort of leaving this off, I
guess, in the sense that I
definitely don't see like any
mass proliferation of the uses
of these types of tools
happening in directly inside of
classrooms, like happening
anytime soon. But, but I think
that, that, finding these
finding these kind of design
language or finding these new
configurations, I think can like
help expand who the who the
willing are, what that coalition
is, and the types of uses for
them?
Vivek Bald: I have a somewhat
tangential question, but I as a
historian and documentarian I c
uldn't let this pass. You m
ntioned that the the project a
Brown in the late 80s also i
volved documentary footage? Y
s. Can you tell me a bit more a
out that? Was there a d
cumentary made about it? Or is i
yes, there was,
Will Freudenheim: I can actually
send it. Yeah, it's a great
documentary, because it
interestingly enough, there
wasn't like a ton of visual
documentation of the project. So
that so the documentary really
helped me out a lot in trying to
understand what was happening at
that point. There was a lot of
quite a few interviews with
students at Brown about their
experience working with the
tool. I didn't I didn't have
time to mention it today. But
there's like quite a few
interesting anecdotes, like some
students about like, using this
shared network to help their
studying was cheating. Like that
they would use these materials
instead of textbook materials,
somehow, like gave them a better
score on their on their test,
like wasn't an authentic way of
learning. And there were other
there were other little
anecdotes about from the English
class about students feeling
like their ideas. Were getting
less like individual creative
people were getting reduced to
the kind of mean, creativity of
the classroom, which was kind of
unexpected point that I thought
was was interesting. But yeah,
the documentary was was really
fascinating. I'd be happy to
send it.
Vivek Bald: Great, thanks. Well,
let's give a round of applause.